in much of asia
and among asians around the world
celebration of the lunar new year is now
underway
the year of the ox officially arrived on
friday
and in a normal year hundreds of
millions of chinese citizens take to
trains planes and roadways to reunite
with family members
but this year of course because of the
pandemic many have chosen
between traditional gatherings and more
modern ways of getting together
raymie innocencio reports now from
beijing
soon jai knows the government is urging
people to stay
home this chinese new year she boarded a
high speed train
anyways with her boyfriend they shot 700
miles south to jiangsu province on the
east coast
to her waiting father and smiling mother
keeping to tradition that families
reunite and
feast during china's biggest holiday of
the year
they did have concerns about kovid if
i'm back
well my family has a risk of
being affected i was a little worried
but then beijing was doing better with
the outbreak said her mom
people should try their best to come
home
many people did travelers buying tickets
this week as a worker sprayed bleach
disinfectant
but many did not before covid chinese
new year was known as the world's
biggest
annual migration hundreds of millions on
the move
this is beijing's central railway
station on chinese new year's eve
normally
there should be thousands of people
rushing to get home
but restrictions now put in place some
of them very harsh include
14 days of mandatory quarantine once you
get home
and that's keeping so many people away
new data show the plunge
74 percent fewer trips taken than in
2019
the year before covet hit air and train
travel
down 80 percent road trips down about a
third
chanyon is one of those millions staying
put
and one of beijing's biggest flower
markets she's prepping to be alone
for spring festival as lunar new year is
known here
living at her family's four bedroom home
her parents have been away in their
hometown since
last april 500 miles south in hanan
province
so how do you feel well i of course feel
really lonely and
kind of sad but chinese has a
term that lair feng chung that means the
future is long and we
will have more time for people who are
traveling
do you have any concern they might be
spreading the coronavirus if they have
it
it's a pretty big risk but it's their
decision
they have the right to go back or stay
like no judgment here
i ask her dad and mom if they're sad
she's not coming back
her mom laughs and says no it's okay the
most
important thing is to be safe as the new
year of the ox begins
for cbs this morning saturday raymie in
ascencio
beijing people born in the year of the
ox are strong reliable
fair and conscientious inspiring
confidence in others
they're also calm patient methodical and
can be trusted
uh they can say little they say little
but can be very opinionated
that sounds like dana oh really dana and
all that positivity
sure why not i'll take okay thank you
sure you and me are out here
i think i'm actually the you're the rat
if i remember oh no
no i don't know what year i hear some
good stuff oh well
good to know jeff yeah there you go a
little research